the first anniversary of their of their
installation of tech there this is this
is all in sugar this is stuck hi are we
on now yeah okay
welcome to the technical typing course
and as I said the I hope people in the
overflow room can can hear me now the
purpose of the course is going to have
each of you who wants to actually type
something with this with this system
called tech this week and get it and get
it you know just to get started on it so
that you know what it's like and you
know whether you're going to want to
type anymore
with it or or not does everyone have a
copy of the handout the handout is
mostly things that I don't want to read
to you in the fact that it talks about
the situation about tech right now at
Stanford campus and and and practical
things about if you don't have an
account for using it how you can get one
and if you have any questions on this
you just see me after after class and
we'll and we'll go over to to the
computer science department and get
accounts for everyone who needs who
needs them if I I think we'll have a
will have enough but it's been it would
be best if people would work in groups I
don't think we can we can start 50 new
accounts for example so if you you might
find it better to work in groups of two
if you're from some other department or
some other place that doesn't have
account but hot let me just check how
many people already know how to use a
computer that that's running tech I'm
and how many do not how many how many
here don't have access to a computer so
that's about about sixty percent do not
so those sixty percent will want to come
over to the computer science department
this afternoon let's say and and get and
get a get guest accounts which for this
week or will allow you to do this so
these sick but please raise your hand if
you've never
use the computer before that's something
okay well this will be a lot of fun for
you I'm sure and also a little bit of
trial because computers don't understand
body language and so on so I so you have
to learn to deal with them in a
different way than dealing with people
but so I for those of for those people I
you take your day or two to get used to
just get used to the idea of a computer
itself and we have students lined up to
help you get get through this people
will be around tonight and every night
this week between 5:15 and 6:15 and and
a little bit before a little bit after
to help people just kidding who are just
brand new getting started as well as to
help people who are having other kind of
problems with the computer okay so so
we're going to try to help everyone get
get started and I know there are some
people in this court that that have
already been using tech for a while and
and they're going to have questions that
are more advanced than the others i'm
going to not i'm going to try to keep
the the level of the class to the
beginners and only if there's a great
demand on thursday or friday then I'll
go into I'll go into things that that
are a little bit more advanced but
there's a there going to be another
class next week that's that's that's a
lot more advanced and I'm not right now
planning to have anything in between
there's sort of they're sort of the one
for the four just starting and then
there's one for the experts and and
assuming that if you're in between
you just get help from people who are
wrap who are around who are who are also
in between
right now although if there's a great
demand for it then I'll go into some of
the in-between topics later on okay now
any questions right off I want to
introduce you to the teaching assistant
because he's a person if you can't find
me around I'll
I'll be trying to be around to help
solve any problems but also you should
you should know Jim he's going to come
in now from the ordinal room
let's there's a chance to be on TV Chand
this Jim Boyce was graciously
volunteered whoops
dick you got him there he is
okay yeah the camera does look at that
okay now this is Jim was graciously
volunteered to be a teaching assistant
this week and so either him or me should
be around if you have problems and one
of the things I want to do is get it
looked at at exactly the problems that
you're having so I'm gonna be walk I'm
gonna be walking around looking at over
people's shoulders and find out what's
what for the trouble is of course my
problem is I've been using technical for
more than three years myself and I can't
remember what it was like the first few
days and so and so I got a watch what
what you know what what you people are
doing and and and and as I recall the
one of the hardest things to learn at
the beginning was just that it wasn't it
wasn't it wasn't immediately direct when
you touch it when you type on a
typewriter you type the an a symbol and
out comes an a on the page and there it
is
and this is nice because you can see
what you've done and you can see exactly
where it where it's going to be on a
page and everything the only thing
that's not nice about it is what if you
didn't want it there then you have to
erase it and move it around now you know
with with tech it's um it's it's quite a
bit different what you type it you type
an A on your terminal and you get an A
into a file but that a doesn't you know
it's just as an instruction to the
computer that sometimes you're going to
want to typeset an A and the computer
and you have to take this this this file
that you've built containing all with
all your manuscript and you have to run
that through a computer program the
computer program will actually put the
on the page so this in this bit the fact
that is indirect that it's not there yet
you know you'll be typing it in but it's
but it's still not not typeset it's a
little bit hard to get used to at the
beginning but I think I think you'll go
again
no no this is the text book does
everyone have a copy of the text book
this if you don't it's anyway you can
get it in the bookstore and or you can
steal one or look look over a neighbor's
copy or something like that the the book
is in three parts the and they the first
part is just an introduction to all of
the the research that I myself was doing
on typography and then comes the middle
part the main part is that is the
complete instruction to tech including
much more than you'll ever want to know
probably about the system the and the
last part is about a system that designs
the letters themselves I won't be
talking about that this week but so the
middle part is the part that you'll be
using and there's an index to the middle
part that you find very helpful but
you'll have to always search for the
index because it still is stuck in the
middle so starting about page page 190
is an index however the there's another
index for the third part you know these
parts are all separately page numbers so
you have to get used to sticking in the
middle of the book to get the index some
people have actually ripped their book
apart put new covers on it and you know
just where the index on okay the the
reason for tag is is to try is to go all
the way for all the way to the finest
possible or the finest possible types of
quality computers when computers were
first used they they could do numbers
only the first in fact the first
attachment to a computer that was that
was used in printing was in 1850 and it
printed tables in in Sweden and then
then gradually computers learn
to do uppercase letters also and then in
fact during the 60s the computers could
even handle lowercase letters and so it
get got a little nice and a little nicer
and pretty soon they could do letters
with variable spacing and and and all of
a sudden it turns out that they that it
got better and better till till we
finally it was finally time to go all
the way to the ultimate wine why not say
anything that that a printer can do you
could do with the computer instead of
just getting something that looks nice
or something that looks good
we wanted something that looks great
that would really that would really be
as well as a printer could do except I'm
not talking about a beautifully
calligraphed manuscripts with gold leaf
and things like this we're not we're not
quite into that into the ultimate in
that way but but what we what what
actually it gives us now the ability to
to have fine printing even though we're
not going through professionals but but
but common people like you and I can can
actually it can actually have fine
printing now well who you can help how
much many of us really need fine
printing and if there's a general
feeling that most most people don't care
that much about how most scientists
don't care that much say about how their
work looks as long as as long as they
get promoted but by writing a paper
that's the only thing important to them
you know is what people say and they
dealt they'll toss it out and and and
some sometimes books would get printed
and so on but most of the time messy
manuscript was okay as long as you got
the point across this was a general
feeling that people that people didn't
really need fine printing very much that
the most surprising thing to me was the
use of tech was how how this how many
people who have for the first time the
power to do this kind of quality
typesetting themselves how how much they
actually get into it and
and and they had this latent desire that
they didn't even know about to make
their to make what they write look
actually beautiful as well
this is very surprising it seems to have
affected more than half of the people
who've had the chance to do it and the
reason was because it was a bet they
didn't know they had this in them before
was because it was so difficult it was
it was difficult to fiddle with
something that's already been printed on
a page and and and and make changes and
and and do it again
now however that is fairly easy to get
this ultimate in quality then it turns
out that a lot of people are really
interested it's amazing how many people
have forgotten excited about about about
fiddling with with with with fine
details of spacing and and this has not
only increased their their their their
joy and getting good printing out but
it's also it's also increased their
dissatisfaction with most of what
printing they see and and so it's sort
of you win some and you lose some right
now I find it almost impossible to read
a book without thinking about this fonts
that are in there and in the spacing and
so on and and and I or I go to a
restaurant in the first ten minutes off
I'll be studying the I'll be studying
the spacing on the menu and then
everything a waiter will come in and and
I won't I won't have even thought about
laughs or the food yet so so this but I
better not talk about food there since
we're at lunch we're meeting a bunch of
time you know okay so so the goal of
tech then is to do is to do really
quality things they're not just adequate
but but but but super the there are the
there's there are other systems that are
very good at making that make they're
making nice-looking reports easy to get
them easy to get the reports done and
and very nice-looking reports especially
described system which we have on campus
and those would be recommended for the
for people whose goal is is to have
have very nice and readable reports but
the purpose of tech is to go beyond very
nice to the to actually super and and
and this means you have to do a little
bit more the the the interesting thing
to me was that it wasn't that much more
to go from to go from the level of good
quality to excellent quality but there
were but you did have to you know pay
some more attention to details there's a
kind of things that though that you
could take pride in these details and
give you a lot of job satisfaction as
you're doing it it's not that much more
work but it still is if you're really
not interested in the high quality then
don't and you don't want a hassle you
don't really care too much about the
fine points so then then tech is a
little bit more powerful and cumbersome
a tool for you to work with then for
something that's just going to produce
lots of reports quickly now okay before
we before I take this away I want
everybody get a good chance to look at
this beautiful tech symbol again that
was made in in sugar by in frosting by
some people last week at the because we
needed some some logo here this is the
the the fact that the e is a little
lower in here means that you pronounce
it that tech and it's my system there I
took there are other systems that are
pronounced text and they and they have
nothing to do with typesetting on the
others specifically there's an operating
system for hunting all computers for
example that's called text and there's
some other systems that are called text
but this one is called tau epsilon Kai
these aren't any T's and E's and XS
these is a these are Greek letters here
and it's a Greek word for art and
technology which is we're trying to
emphasize here beautiful printing and
all that stuff so you have a handout
let's see I got to get to get through
all the preliminaries you got this
handout and it tells as I said how to
get computer accounts and there's also a
problem that we're having today that
according to this handout you're
supposed to use the dover printer to
print your
to print your homework your exercises
but the Dover printer has been down
since Friday and and we have some people
over at Xerox this afternoon trying to
look at the specs and test out and find
out what's wrong with our boards and and
we feel that it'll be ready tomorrow but
not tonight so that means that there are
a couple of changes to this handout that
you make in order to run tonight if you
get as far as actually getting something
through tech so I can quick give you the
patches to this in the first place when
you run when you run the program
according to the manual if you're if
you're normally running tech I'd say all
you and say are te X into the operating
system this means run and this is T X
but instead for today since we're going
to have to use another version that goes
to the xgp printer you say r XG p te X
and that gets you the old version of
tech that that comes out and XE p XC p
is the printer that produced this
handout actually this this particular
handout is it was run on the on this
Xerox graphics printer which is our old
printer it's not as good a quality as
you get off of the off of the Dover but
it's but it's good enough for our
purposes today then then instead of
using the word over here you say XS
which which which get which prints on
the xgp
Wow and furthermore your your your your
output of this version of tech is going
to be called paper dot xgp instead of
paper dot p re and so that so those
those two changes are also so you have
so you start out and and on a computer
you make up a manuscript file which will
be called paper te x and then then you
send it to the to the xgp tech computer
program the xdp tech computer program
reads in what you tell your manuscript
file and outcomes to other files one is
called errors temp this is the one that
just records and
errors that that type detected in your
manuscript these errors are are going to
be some we're going to be talking about
a lot this week because it's one of the
things you're going to have to learn how
to get through everybody makes mistakes
and and especially when you're when
you're working with a computer that
that's going to check to see whether
what what you typed in might make sense
to it but but not exactly the sense that
you had in mind so so we'll see we'll
talk a lot about errors this week and
huh
but this this file also records for me
what what you did and and if you make a
copy of this and you have any trouble
you can show this file to me and I'll be
able to tell what went what went wrong
and how you can avoid the problem so so
when you run this program it probably it
reads your your paper T X file and it
produces two of its own the one called
paper dot xgp contains everything that
that the that this xgp machine needs to
to produce a final copy like like the
handout itself that were that we're
looking at now so the fat so for example
at the very top if you look in fine
print this will say hand xgp so the
piece of paper you're holding was was
saw was really printed for by this
printer by this xgp printer and it was
called you see it was done this morning
at 9:35 and it was and this is the name
of the file a time and and the page and
so on and it and and the dot xgp file
was was the instructions to the printer
how to how to make this page look look
the way it does so the print so and tell
it where to put all the letters and
what's a bottle letters and everything
to use there was another program hand
TDX which I which I file hand I TX which
I which I actually typed into the
computer this is the one that that
describes the handout and we'll look at
this to see to get examples of
alright those of you who haven't used
computers before will find that your
first learning experience will be mostly
just learning how to how to how to type
in a anything to the computer how to
make you know how to make a file that
contains your instructions to tech so so
tonight we'll probably be going just
through that hassle and you won't even
have run anything through tech by
tomorrow so others of you though who
already know that will be able to start
experimenting with tech itself tonight
and we'll have it as I said we're gonna
have people around to help you get to
get over whatever hurdles you have to
get over in whatever level you're at
right now I'm going to first talk about
how you use tech to do straight copy and
then I'll talk about using about doing
doing technical things with it and and
and mathematics and each of you I hope
has something in mind that you would
like to use tech for some some yeah some
sample job that you would like to types
it if you if you haven't got anything in
mind you might run around the computer
science building and see if there's any
anybody's work needs to be done or you
could just pick a random book out of the
library and and do that I'm thinking of
something that's going to come out to be
four or five pages long not fifty forty
or fifty pages on at the end of the week
we haven't got that much extra computer
resources probably for it for this four
hundred people to do a forty before each
forty uh things during the day time
because our computers already saturated
but I'm thinking a four or five page
exercise that would that would give that
would give you get you really started
and enough to after that you would have
you would you would be on your way to be
doing just about you know any the longer
papers but let that be next week and
then you there'll be other a lot of
people around that can help you
question yeah question by the end of
this week will we be equipped for
putting things in boxes and things like
that or is that into next week I think
you'll be able to do you'll be able to
do a lot of that but not but not
arbitrary you can arbitrarily
complicated thing one of the things
about printing is that that it's been
going on for over 500 years and every
year somebody thinks of a new thing to
do and so this is a lot of things have
accumulated over the over time and and
so there's some inherent complexity and
I like I can't teach in this one week
everything how you do everything at a
printer has ever thought of doing during
500 years so I'm going to try to cover
as the most important things still
you'll find that every user of tech will
find that as you go through a year every
week you might see something a little
bit different that you would like to do
or something that you didn't even know
you'd like to do you you might think of
doing something that printers haven't
even ever thought of before and so
there's a look so I can't really answer
exactly what the cutoff is going to be
but but but we're going to be able to do
quite a lot of powerful things this
weekend and I'm going to look mostly at
the things that people need for the
papers that they that they that they're
doing if you have a if you have a really
complicated application I'm going to
have to defer it though and just talk to
you about it personally because we only
have a limited amount of time during the
during the class I want to make sure I
don't lose the people who are just
starting oh okay
now now in this room you can also ask
questions and there's a microphone in
front of you to see that little black
thing by the TV set you put your people
if you want to ask a question just raise
your hand and then you pick up the
microphone you push the red button in
and this is a casaba it's a really fancy
stuff any but aren't there any questions
in here must be a question yes she just
wants to try playing with the microphone
the xgp prayer in the same room is the
dover that is oh no that's right I'm
sorry I gotta change the room it's up in
the fourth floor it's it's
I don't know the number of the room it's
up on the fourth floor it's a the it's a
great big it's okay as you come to the
top of the steps on the fourth floor
you you go sort of towards your right
and and and that's where that's the
direction toward it there will be people
that will help you I guess yes
oh where are the terminals that were
supposed to use for connecting to the
ground or on four terminals over in Jack
saw so you come over there and after
five o'clock we'll be able to do it I
mean I'll let you can use my terminal
and so on people who come who come over
you should come before 5:00 to get an
account because Susan Susan will be
going home
Susan will be going home at normal time
tonight she's the one who gets you
started with an account otherwise you'd
have to use one of our one of our own
accounts but but I
but we're just going to go and go
through the building I have a master key
and I can steal and sneak any money okay
for people who have access to score will
it's okay to use the oh yeah that's
please do because we don't want to have
you know there's about a hundred people
and we we don't we don't have enough bus
to handle everybody coming through so so
the score computer and and the Burien
over in in this building upstairs here
would be good it wouldn't be best also
because if you already have access to
score that means that that's what you'll
be wanting to use for your for your for
your work content as I say on the
handout the the present at present we
have five different ways to use the
output of tech on campus however there's
there's going to be many more in within
a year and and but right right now right
now it would be from for most of you I
think just getting getting exposure to
what it would be like when when these
other systems
around the campus later on Christian
pre-recording Xerox as it hosts true
well for people who are here visiting
from Xerox please go to Xerox and use it
use and use the tech guy at Xerox yeah
you've got a very excellent installation
of tech they're one of the one in the
bill Christian yes what are the
possibilities of getting long term
accounts how much does it cost
you'll have to ask me that after class I
don't want to take the time for that now
okay and so now when we start using it
the first thing is just to type straight
copy things that don't have mathematics
in it what do you do and the answer is
it's almost like just typing it on a
typewriter there's just a few things
that that make it different but to do
fine pruning from from ordinary printing
let's see if I can look at this at this
hand out and see and and and come and
see anything that was a special okay
well first of all of course like I this
top line here is in bold faces these
letters are a little darker then then
the rest of them on the Dover you see it
a lot better than on the xgp but it's
true then also there I lowered the e in
tech and so on okay
let's let's defer that question though
for a minute I just I got right myself
notes here of things that I that I plan
to cover so the only thing unusual as I
see here in these first lines is the
fact that the e is lowered in tact and
otherwise I'm just typing in pretty much
the same so so let's take a look at
these at these at the paragraph C guest
accounts on the sale computer will be
available this week for people who don't
already have access to tech now what I
did here is I define a special thing
that's going to typeset the letter the
logo protect every time it occurs this
backslash character is the instructions
this is gonna be a special there's gonna
be something special coming up here it's
not just ordinary if I had left out the
backslash it would just go like a te ex
into the file but putting a backslash in
it says that somewhere I should have
defined what what this what this
instruction is it's a lot of the the
instructions are already known to tech
those that are already known are all
listed in the index of the manual but
this particular one was was was was not
known to text so I had so actually I
defined it up here with some long
long-winded things which we are going to
look at for now it's just saying that
there is a way to tell it to make this
letters te ex with the e you know
squeeze to get a little bit more the e
dropped the point is right now that I
type a backslash in front of such an
instruction and then that that's an
abbreviation now you won't be having to
do that in your in the manuscripts that
you that you're working on although you
might have something else that that is
really unusual about that manuscript if
so you would get a tech wizard to to
tell you how to make a definition like
like this one up here which is which is
sort of wizard okay now to sign up for
such an account so I just typed the rest
of this all exactly as it would be
notice though that it doesn't matter
where I break the lines at the end of
the at the end of each line the Li the
carriage return at the end of every line
is just like a space as far as tech is
concerned it doesn't see any difference
between a carriage return in the space
and so so afterwards when we got the
paragraph actually actually said the
lines the lines came out so that
everything would be even at the right
hand okay now
I I guess there wasn't that much then in
this whole example oh yes oh yeah I'm
glad you asked that filling now okay
what
except I'm planning to talk about that
later
I'm sorry I'm gonna go on what it does
the the quick answer is that this means
that it won't break a line at the end of
the - okay but but that's that's a
problem that loop that you run into in a
minute I think I'll get to that I'll get
to that later today
okay now I guess the first thing the the
first thing that I can talk about is
about these lease they're called control
sequences it starts with a backslash and
then if a bunch of letters and then a
control sequence ends with the first
thing that isn't a letter so here for
example I had a and apostrophe night
wasn't a letter so so so that the
sequence ended there but now notice up
here where I said tech then I had a
space and then then n IC al now a space
following a control sequence is always
ignored because as far as tech knows it
was the way you wanted to end the
control the name of the control sequence
if I didn't have that space there the
control sequence would have to be
technical and I haven't defined any
control sequence of technical so so I
had to put the space there but actually
I didn't want his face in me in the in
the handout okay well his spaces are
ignored
after the control sequence so that was
fine in that case but what about the
next place where where I'm typing
something like tech is presently running
as Stanford and I do want a space after
it I got to do something about that to
get that space in okay so I had to worry
a little about that and the answer is
you use a backslash in a space that
means there's the space okay so I so I
had to remember because because Tech was
this with a special control sequence I
had
that the space after it gets gobbled up
and doesn't you know it doesn't appear
finally and so I had to put this
backslash space after it that's a little
bit of a hassle remembering if I was
using something like that remembering
that I'm going to lose the space after
it so so you get used to putting in an
extra backslash space in a place where
you want a space to occur otherwise the
space would not appear
similarly if if you leave five spaces in
a row Tech doesn't treat star the same
as it as if it was one space so if you
want five spaces in a row you say
backslash space backslash space
backslash space five times question yes
can you use a backslash instead of a
space a backslash space but not no
backslash you know in the example when
you will you say that you left a space
as an end of a special instruction
backslash itself would end in
instruction another instruction but see
this backslash is beginning a second
instruction and and the second
instruction is backslash space now my
question refer to that whether your
technique Carla TX / and I yes
will that work now if I put up if I put
a backslash in here in between right
right then it would then it would say
the control sequence TX and and the
control sequence nickel and it would
look to see what is nickel mean and it
wouldn't find it would probably say
undefined control sequence and you get
an error message it would say undefined
control sequence nickel doesn't know one
nickel mean it's okay
know so backslash really is saying to
tech watch out something is coming after
this black backslash that's special read
what's look at what coming after it and
see what it is now the thing after the
backslash is eat if the thing after the
backslash is a letter then it looks
until you get to the end of the letters
but if the thing after the backslash is
not a letter then and then it's just
just one symbol long and and that's for
example backslash
case is an example of that it's not the
space isn't a letter okay I think you
get into that you'll understand now let
me see before I talk anymore about this
handout I wanted to talk about some more
straight text I decided I just got this
book from the bookstore beautiful book
called Stanford from the foothills to
the bay and so I thought that I would
look inside there and it and just to get
a random sample of what - what the
typeset and and I chose the first I
decided that I'll just open the book and
whatever page I came to first that would
be what I would use as an example this
morning and I opened to page 36 and I
got this a story about about the early
years of Stanford okay now if you see
right off in fact you can't see it in
color but this s is in is in red so
right off there is something fancy that
the printer had done here to get that to
get that s to come come down and and and
in this in this class I won't explain to
you how you get that that doing because
it's not typical for technical typing
however next week that'll be one of the
first exercises that we do so forth so
what what I did was then in order to
type this this account I made a
definition of something called fancy
alright and then when I typed the list
of the paragraph I said fancy senator
and mrs. Stanford and and I'll tell you
about why I put a backslash after mrs.
very soon so I just said fancy and then
that s got set God said fancy okay and
and it moved the second line over and
did the right thing okay so this is a
way it's possible to do these things
with tech but when you if you need them
just for the for the time being when
you're starting out ask a wizard to make
you making your control sequence for the
for the particular application and then
after a month of that then look at what
then start to look at what these wizards
are doing for you and after after five
months of that start being a wizard for
somebody else that's the that's the way
it works now but anyway control
sequences then can can be designed to do
lots of lots of things and as far as
you're considering right now though is
there sort of magical things that
wizards will do for it okay now when we
look at this at this text we see we see
one thing that's that's different from
typing and that's these quote marks you
see on a typewriter you only you have
your double quote symbol but what
printers have two kinds they have
opening quotes and ending quotes right
and so that was one of the things that I
had to watch out as I typed the
manuscript and so to get the opening
quotes I typed on onic on your computer
terminal you'll see there's two kinds of
there's an apostrophe in a reverse
apostrophe so I typed the reverse
apostrophe two of them here at the
beginning and two regular apostrophes
you can't see it too well on your TV
screen but this is a these are regular
apostrophe these are reverse apostrophes
and those both appear on it you can type
both of these into the computer but
there's one simple their single symbols
and you type you type in one at a time
and then that reads this and and this is
one of the ligature combinations that
recognizes two two opening quotes in a
row get changed into a single opening
double quote mark okay so that's one
thing that's different from a typewriter
view if you would sit there and use your
double quote on the typewriter it would
actually turn out that I think you get
you get ending quotes yes
automatically adjust the spacing between
the two quotes that's it that's right it
does that it does that you see the you
see well that this is of course the book
that was printed but if you look at what
tech what tech did with it this is what
happen is what came out okay so so the
spacing does come out automatically the
only tricky thing is if you have three
you know if you put three in a row like
you want double quotes and then followed
by a single quote Oh
or did you mean single quote followed by
double quote and you want to get just
the right amount of spacing in between
but you don't want to line to break from
you know you know one you don't want to
break you know between the end of a line
between the double quote at the end of
one line and the single quote at the
beginning of the next line or something
like that right so and computer is going
to be stupid and break at any space
unless you're unless you're careful
about so there are special control
sequences developed for for applications
where you're going to have a lot of
quotes inside of quotes if you so the
common case is you just have double
quotes and you type them this simple
this simple way okay now another thing
that that in fact this paragraph was
nice because it illustrated the that the
two things that are most different
between printing and typing noises -
here the when you're typing you know if
you have to make a dash while you make a
bunch of hyphens and here's a - this
looks quite different - of course and
this - is is long now actually there's
something in between this - and hype and
also that cleaners use and you see it
later on on another page of this book
this this this long - is called an M -
and then there's an N - which is only
half as long and so with tech you you
got to learn the difference between
different kind of hyphens and dashes and
the idea is a hyphen is just an ordinary
- but an end - is two hyphens and em -
is three hyphens so when I'm typing this
particular example and I after the word
shadow I use three dashes there okay I
didn't put spaces before and after you
see there aren't spaces for now some
people like basically for and after
dashes but it's just pretty much grown
on I think okay now the other thing is
why did I put this backslash arrow yeah
it got a question this text still no to
break at the end
- before the - or at the end of the - or
ok tank will break after it after any -
or any - but not before in fact I think
a lot of people most people frown on
breaking before it if you want to allow
a break there there's another control
sequence that you could do saying a
possible break here but but mostly you
just type it this way and this would
this would allow a break after the - and
that leads me to Phyllis's question what
if you didn't want to break after after
a particular - or after a particular -
because because it because I see genius
question is where is it allowed to
essentially went when we when we get
this at the you know lines end at
certain places but how does technology
know it's okay to end there and not in
but not to end in the middle of a word
or something like that well late the
places that are allowed to break our
spaces between words and after hyphens
and dashes okay that's why I said if you
if you had two quotes separated by a
space you want to do something special
so that that space wouldn't be
considered as a possible place where you
could where you could break between
lines now what what if you didn't want
to to break though after a hyphen and
that's what came out in our handout here
I was giving Jim voices phone number and
and I didn't know if it was gonna come
at the end of a line or not but it might
have and so if I had if I had just left
and if I had just typed the phone number
after 497 - it might have considered
this as a - so start a new line with the
1658 and well there's and so I what I
did was like I made this all into a box
I will explain exactly what H Box means
later on in the course but by putting
anything into a box
this means treat it as a unit that's
that you can't split up there's no one
since once something is put into a box
it's just like a single letter
type and so when I said eh box bracket
of something closed the bracket that
that says whatever is inside of that is
treated exactly as if it was a
indivisible unit that gets to this as if
it was a big you know a big letter or
something like that and that that that
that keeps Tech from ever than breaking
a line in the middle of it okay so that
was a that we'll talk more about that
later so so usually in other words
usually you like the fact that it'll
automatically break at the end of a - or
- but there are some times when those
those just don't seem psychologically
good places to break okay now why did I
put the backslash in front of the space
in Stanford does anybody have an idea
it's cut it's a logo missus no the just
is spacing between the dot and yes this
is the period yeah because of the period
here this is it tech depending on how
the font of type is set up the designer
the funnel type is said how much space
to put between ordinary words and how
much space to put after periods and
these are these are are independently
controlled so after a period on this
particular phone of type you get a
little bit more space than then between
words other people like French spacing
which doesn't do that but there will be
slightly more space here before the
before the B and but and after that and
and some people say that psychologically
this is better because you your your
prising at the end of a sentence or a
new you know gives your mind just a tiny
little bit of extra time to get ready
for the next sentence and so there's a
little extra space there well if but how
is that going to know that this first
period wasn't the end of a sentence and
it wouldn't put this little extra space
at the end of that for a sense so when
you're typing a word that ends in you
know some abbreviations ends with a
period then you say then then again
you put for the control space after it
you know otherwise you get a little like
you get too much space between the two
okay so I had to do that a couple of
times I had to do it for dr. Jordan but
I hope I did something different in the
next next paragraph okay now so to
summarize what I said so far the the
main differences between ordinary
straight typing and and typing to get
the quality that you get for printer is
that you worry about you that you you
distinguish between quote marks opening
quotes and closing quotes and you
distinguish between dashes and then
sometimes you have to worry about where
word lines are going to break on you if
you don't worry about that at the
beginning you'll see it sometimes in the
output and then you and then you will
you will patch that up now as I said
tech strives to get to get fine printing
and and I did this example to be to be
similar to the to be the the line width
of the original although I don't have
the same the same spacing between
letters and and it turned out that well
it didn't break the lines exactly the
same as was in the published book the
published book had a had a a rather
loose line here with fairly wide spaces
between words Affairs during their
lifetimes and the next line it's a
little bit tight parsing onto all the
money so tech actually put power on this
previous line but there might be little
different with it with a different style
of type but the but one of the things
that tech does is it reads your whole
paragraph before it decides how it's
going to divide it up into lines so that
the the end of the paragraph can
influence if there's something bad
coming up on the end of the paragraphs I
mean it would be hard to split or
something like that then the earlier
parts of the paragraph will be adjusted
so that so that this
is taken care of and and one of the
other things we say the most important
other thing about straight text that
that should be noted is is something
that that I call cycle to avoid
psychologically bad breaks and it's
something that seems to have have come
in mostly because of computer
typesetting well some well if a human
operator is sitting there deciding where
the end of every line is going to be
some then maybe subconsciously you don't
even think of ending a line at a place
that's that's a little bit
psychologically bad but sometimes what
the computer has to be told that some
places some some breaks aren't quite so
nice like I said in the middle of a
phone number now an example is if the if
you're ending a say Elysee suppose
somebody says see Figure one and you
turn the pit you'll see figure then turn
the page one end of paragraph it doesn't
look very good or even if it's in the
medieval one line you say see figure and
then one is that the next one is usually
especially if the word figure is
abbreviated you usually like to have
figure 1 as a unit without breaking in
between the two similarly between names
somehow my own name for example Donald
EKU's it would look better to me if said
Don - old iike Knuth then if it was
Donald and then e Knuth on the next line
you know it's you can break or Donald I
on this line but and includes on next
line is ok but somehow the break between
the between the Donald and the e isn't
there isn't so it isn't so good
and it's the same with a lot of titles
and also when you're in scientific work
quite often you're you this happens most
often in mathematical things that when
you have units of measure you say three
inches you don't want to have three on
once and in on the next line
abbreviation or something like that so
so to avoid psychologically bad breaks
it turns out that the reason I'm
bringing it up is it
it occurs in this next paragraph here
Collis P Huntington and I thought I'd
tell tech not to break between Collis
and P if if at all possible and so I I
made up a little I made up a little a
special instruction detect which I which
this is that this is a little bit of
magic that to tell you about later but
any but the main point is now I can use
a double arrow symbol and and that will
that will give me a space that is is
undesirable for breaks and so I use that
here come instant after college P
Huntington by the way a period this P is
also an abbreviation but tech doesn't
doesn't add extra space if it follows a
capital letter if the period follows a
capital letter it doesn't consider that
to be the end of the sentence because
because that's so common to have a to
have an initial like that but I'm
putting up but I quit this double arrow
in between saying this is try to tie
these words together on the same line if
you can but I did it wrong didn't I I
should have put it here hmm a little bit
of a problem there okay sorry and then I
did the same after permit after missus
Stanford and dr. Joe Jordan this oughta
automatically also gives it a normal
space instead of a space after a
sentence this is a this this is this
refinement tend to to avoid
psychologically bad breaks is is
probably the only other thing that's
that separates site a typing of straight
text it's the most common thing that
occurs in typing straight text and your
quote marks your dashes and and
psychologically bad breaks after in
certain places
yeah question
want that to be the end of a sentence
how do you take care of that how do I
take care of that then that's described
in the manual there's you you say no at
the end like you say supported by
supported by the NSF and then you want
then comes a period right and so if you
say for example NSF no period is one way
to do it to see there's other ways but
that's one way the way I usually use
okay so there are ways to fool tech the
other way around - it's the practice
it's terrible that that period has to
cover all these things and I would have
to have been unable to think of a way
that would automatically do all of these
things question is that double arrow
symbol a standard character on the ASCII
keyboard this is this is a character on
it on the sail keyboard only you can use
another character if you don't want it
so so I gave what I did was in this in
this but when we have it on the screen
what I did was I said that character
whose ASCII code is 27 is going to be
used for this purpose and whatever
character if I wanted to use an odd sign
or something like that I could do it but
then I'd use a I'd use ASCII code 100
instead of 27 for that so so in fact for
different keyboards you you would you
would use a different character for this
but but it's the most natural and to use
on our computer I I defined that this is
not part of tech yeah and what it said
is that you I mean what I did was saying
that when I typed that it means a
control space and then a penalty in
front of it saying a bad place to break
up between lines that's it but that's
besides but that's that's what I define
that to me there's a shorthand for
saying a bad place to break but then
give a space all right now let me see I
see that we're only got we only had five
minutes left to go and I and I didn't
and so I better defer that talking about
mathematical formulas until tomorrow so
I just talked to rest the other five
minutes about straight about straight
text I turn to another page in here
which talks about the building that
we're
done yeah on this example you didn't
talk about how to center that line right
yeah that's right at the very very
beginning I mean let's talk about the
beginning of the handout right so that
would because that's that's something
that's easy to to see how we did
so the very top line here we had this is
Nelson and so how did I do that read
this line here it says ctrl IND that's
the control sequence Center make a
centered line okay
center line and then I type this brace
this opening brace symbol and then the
encoding brace that all of that is
supposed to be centered on a line okay
and that will do it
it's now the bf means boldface so this
is the next control sequence I said here
that's boldface applies to this thing
the centered when I typed VF that's that
is this is a control sequence that is is
not standard to tech but but but almost
always used by people and at the very
top line of the file I said input basic
which brings in the most common the most
common control sequences that people
that people need so so so I very first
line of this file said input basic which
brought in the standard and the manual
talks about all the control sequences in
basic one of them is CTR line one of
them is VF so this one gives you a
boldface type and and bility the center
on the line
the next line here said V size 11
through inches that's why this page is
long it says that it should be 11 inches
well at 11 inches of copy on one page
the next thing to find a special font
that I was using that isn't in basic it
isn't a basic font when you get to the
bottom of the handout here it's it's
it's in a typewriter like font and so
are you so that's why I brought in this
typewriter font on my third line here
these are things that that you don't
that you won't need for your first day
sighs I just inflame for those of you
who know and so that so the first real
thing so actually if you're doing your
own paper the first line of your file
you would say input basic and then the
second line would say centerline and
then you wouldn't have to do wouldn't
have any special thing like a control
sequence for something special like tech
okay
the next line is the only other thing I
want to do yes we have a question yes
below you Polk award modification did
you do it yourself or the injected it
the the word modification I broke by
myself yeah I'll get to it I'll answer
that in a sec Thanks
the one thing the next thing I mentioned
here is I I said we skip 12 PT and that
gave that gave the space between between
this line and this one these skip means
a vertical spacing and so twelve points
of the vertical spacing was added there
PTAs points and 12 points is about one
lines worth sixth of an inch so so I
said assent I could have also said we
skipped point one six in4 sixth of an
inch of something like that that but V
skip was what made the line in the space
between this line and the next one now
we had this question why did I have mod
control backslash - if the backslash - K
back such - shunts there okay and the
reason is that I wanted to hyphenate
that word and tech didn't - it correctly
technically the reason is that it has
this fi fi the in fine printing letter F
followed by I is it gets gets typeset as
a special character it's different and
so it doesn't look like so it looks to
tech as if this word has a has been all
made out of letters because it had that
ligature in it and so the hyphenation
algorithms got mixed up so I had to
hyphenate this one manually this said
this said you know these are these are
desirable places
put hyphens in if you need to the
question yeah going back to your to the
title line again the both basic the
boldface command apparently takes in
more than just the next few where's
terminated it goes to the difficult if
you give a command of change of change
of font it goes to the end of the level
of braces where it's in so centerline
for example is inside braces so so the
boldface disappeared after if you didn't
yep
if I had said boldface up here and not
here then it would then then everything
would be both face but since the since
this was this boldface was inside of
braces it goes away afterwards and oh
that's that's something that I guess we
didn't see we didn't see how to get
italics because there's no italics on
this copy but there's but you do the
same yeah yeah there was one in the in
the Stanford book will we'll see it next
time here's that here's an example where
I had to say fortune magazine
okay and so that's very easy to to do
you just say let me see term and also
well we here we go
fortune I said I said brace metallic
fortune close brace and so fortune was
in italics but nothing else okay here I
had a hyphenated University by by hand
actually I wouldn't have had to do that
but we talked about that one more
question and time is up I'm sorry
there's people awaiting
are you indicating the beginning of a
new paragraph by entering a blank line
in the info yeah discussion thank you
very much I forgot to I forgot to tell
you that's a very basic thing these
blank lines here are terrifically
important that's that that tells tech
that's it that's the end of a paragraph
time to start a new one and especially
the last one the the very end the
I also don't tell you what you got to do
at the end so at the beginning of your
file you say input basic at between
paragraphs you give a blank line and at
the very end of the file you should you
should give a blank line and then V fill
and then in these control sequences V
fill means fill it with a lot of space
as much as as much as you need to fill
the page and and n means this is this is
the end of the whole of the whole
manuscript so you need that at the end
otherwise tech will just keep waiting
for more all right so you'll have
problems with it of course today but
that's